c'est de chevaux sous le capot le Rallye
cœurs de France est de retour dans notre
région pour sa 25e édition 70
concurrents étaient au départ ce matin à
mazenger petite commune près de Vendôme
au programme de cette manche du
championnat de France cette épreuve sur
226 km Florent Clavel était parmi les
spectateurs sur le bas-côté des routes
[Applaudissements]
le bruit des pneus qui crient sur la
sfalte juste avant l'épingle à cheveux
le ralliqueur de France a repris
possession du Perche Vendômois nous
sommes sur l'une des 7 spéciales du jour
le public est venu en nombre ce qu'il
apprécie la puissance des voitures déjà
puis les trois premiers
il y a du sport
[Musique]
envisageable
ça m'est arrivé ça fait chier
pour cette 25e édition du rallye plus de
70 voitures sont engagées les preuves
compte pour la 7e manche du championnat
de France sur asphalte elle attire les
meilleures pilotes de l'Hexagone
parmi eux Yohann Bonato champion de
France en titre qui pointait en tête ce
matin c'était un rallye qui est très
rapide par rapport à ce qu'on peut
rencontrer habituellement il y a
beaucoup de virages qui peuvent être
coupés dans l'herbe rendant le terrain
souvent glissant dans ces zones là donc
voilà c'est un terrain à la fois rapide
et à la fois ça les glissant ou encore
le local de l'étape le tour en jeu
tonicosson et sa Porsche lui aussi un
habitué de l'épreuve endommoise de la
région il y a toujours beaucoup de monde
il y a une belle ferveur autour de se
rallye donc c'est le rallye de ne pas
manquer en tout cas ça c'est sûr on peut
dire que le cœur de France est encore le
Petit Poucet par rapport à des épreuves
qui sont là depuis 30 ans 40 ans mais la
qualité de l'organisation qui est
reconnue par tous par par les team fait
que le cœur de France a tout de suite
trouvé sa place en championnat de France
et c'est une un rendez-vous
incontournable de la saison demain si
spécial entre Sarthe et Loir-et-Cher
sont au programme de la course avec un
premier départ de sujet à 8h58 toutes
les informations sur le site Internet
rally cœur de france.org
[Musique]